- [Mark] All right, Karina.
Karina, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from?
- I'm from Mexico.
- [Mark] Oh, really?
- Yes.
- [Mark] And he came
to the US at what age?
- Two.
- [Mark] And, tell me about your parents.
You had both, you had both
your parents in your life?
- Yeah, I do.
Yeah.
- [Mark] Good childhood?
- Hmm?
- No (chuckles).
- [Mark] What kind of stuff went on?
- Like they were like,
don't worry about money
and that's it and that's all.
And it's still the same way.
That's why I left.
They fight for money.
There's like, I don't know it's just,
I'm glad I'm not there no more.
- [Mark] And you went
on your own at what age?
- I was
13.
- [Mark] 13. That's early.
- Yeah. I was tired--
- [Mark] Why did you
leave your parents at 13?
- Huh?
- [Mark] Why'd you leave your
parents at 13?
- Because I was tired of
them not being the parents.
I was like, I'm tired.
They didn't let me go out like, nowhere.
If I would go to the door they'd be like,
where are you going, just
get in your room and,
they're always like,
I don't know, it was only about them.
They, they were very selfish.
And they still are.
- [Mark] So what'd you do
with your life from 13 on?
Did you finish high school?
- No.
All my life--
- [Mark] Did you go to high school?
- Yeah. (chuckles)
- [Mark] So, so today
you're living on Skid Row.
- Yeah, but when I, when I came over here,
- [Mark] How did you get down here?
- Oh my God, It's a long story.
Well, let me make it a
little shorter. Okay.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Um,
I met this man,
that he was the normal man
before he did crystal meth.
Now he's cool.
And,
he, I, I met him and
he used to beat my ass
and he used to like,
like abuse me in front of
my baby, stuff like that.
So I got tired of it
and I was in La Habra and I
got tired of it and I left.
When I left, I came over here
but I was, I think it was,
I think this, this, this
thing happened because,
because it was karma.
Because like,
I was at church
and I was tryna get a
ride to get down here,
like around 12 o'clock
or one o'clock in the,
like in, in the, in the nighttime
and then I went to church
and I tell this lady at
church, can you hug my baby?
Because I wanted to take a line.
So I went to the bathroom
and a do to, take the line, you know?
And then when I came over here,
I didn't knew they had to drug test me to,
for me to stay there.
I had to give them a drug
test, but I barely took a line.
So, so I opened my fucking mouth
and I told this lady,
they work right there.
You know what um, well
yeah, I'm dirty on meth,
that's why I don't wanna take my test.
And boom! They open a,
a, what'd you call the,
what you call that thing, the,
the child protective services?
- [Mark] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then they, they took my son away.
Because they put it as
a positive and then,
then, (chuckles)
then the good story is coming.
Then I kept, okay, now I'm here down here
and then I'm, I was an alcoholic.
I used to drink a lot.
I used to be an alcoholic for real,
like number one alcoholic.
But then I got here and I met
Sharkey.
And when I met Sharkey, I don't
know what the fuck happened,
I don't know, I don't know, I don't know,
I don't know, but it's,
it's so weird, okay.
I can't drink no more.
I hate alcohol.
I've been clean for 11 months
almost because of Sharkey.
He told me, if you wanna get drunk,
go to the corner and go with
those drunkies and get drunk
because you making me broke.
And then, and then I
stopped and then I stopped.
And then now when I, I don't wanna drink.
It's like, disgusted.
Oh! And then another little
story I'ma put in that one.
And then, I wanted to
get pregnant by Sharkey,
and I used to get mad at him and be like,
gosh! Sharkey, you don't cum inside of me.
Damn it!
He goes, again, again.
And guess what happened?
Boom! A baby in my stomach now.
So now I'm four months pregnant and,
I'ma have a baby, another Sharkey.
- [Mark] Congratulations.
So are, are you using
currently, crystal meth?
- Well, (sighs) I am trying
my best to not use it,
but it's the worstest of the worstest.
I'm fighting it so bad.
It's very hard.
- [Mark] It's gonna be a
bad thing for the baby.
- But know what, I'm gonna make it.
And I know I'm gonna go through this and,
I'm gonna have my baby and I'm not gonna,
I'ma all right.
- [Mark] What are you waiting for?
- Hmm?
- [Mark] What are you waiting
for?
- What do you mean waiting for?
- [Mark] Are you four,
are you four months in?
- It's only, well, I'm
for five months to know,
and then I'm gonna have my baby.
But, besides that, I have
another problem and top of that,
I have a baby in the system.
He's two
and,
it was very hard, Oh my God, I don't know,
I don't know, sometimes I feel
like I'm not gonna make it.
- [Mark] You feel like crying?
- I feel like crying.
- [Mark] Everybody cries here.
I got Kleenex.
What's the worst part of losing your kid?
Did you ever see him?
- Yes. I see him every Wednesday.
He's, he was so attached to me like,
I just feel like I'm not gonna make it.
Like, I feel like they're gonna
take both of the babies away
if I don't do this for real.
If I don't take this serious.
You know,
in reality I'm not taking
this serious right now
and I have to.
I have to take it serious cause,
cause I know if I lose this
baby and I lose the other baby,
he ain't gonna fuck with me.
Nobody's gonna fuck with me.
They're gonna be like,
damn! Look at that girl,
you know like, she,
she aint nothing.
- [Mark] How, how old are you?
- Huh?
- [Mark] How old are you?
- 35.
- [Mark] 35.
- But there are, this neighborhood
there's people who are 45, 55, 65.
They're still down here.
- Yeah. And you know what?
It's very hard.
I've been raped before and
stuff like that, and I made it.
And I, I don't cry no more
for that because I, I,
I will never, Alfred,
I forgive him already
but I will never forget that,
but I don't cry no more.
It's, it doesn't phase me no more.
It just went away already like,
I don't think about that no more.
But it hurt me right now, the
most it's hurting me right now
is that I cannot leave the stuff alone.
Like the party, like I wanna still party
but I wanna have my baby.
But I feel like I, I can,
I'm not gonna make it.
Like, sometimes I feel
like I'm not gonna make it.
But I pray every day.
Every day I pray to God cause
I know He, He got my back.
And when I walk around with Him
and we walk around and go do our things,
I'm talking to myself but I'm,
I'm talking to God and telling Him, God,
okay, He needs to change
my mind and my brain
and my soul and everything
in a different way.
I need to be a better mom.
I got six kids.
- [Mark] You have six kids?
- I have six kids.
- Did you raise any of them?
- No.
I had never been a mom.
I was being a drunkie,
alcoholic.
And then I met Sharkey
and then everything went,
I've been clean for 11 months so,
and you know what?
It was not hard
- [Mark] Clean from
alcohol but not, not meth?
- Not, not meth and all
this, but from alcohol, Yeah.
I'm, I'm been clean, very clean and,
it doesn't phase me.
You can drink in front
of me and I feel like,
how can you drink that shit?
That's what, and it's amazing,
if I go back to my old friends in Gardena,
cause that's my half,
half of my life I, I was raised all there.
And then the other half in San Diego.
And, if I go back to Gardena and,
they're not gonna believe it.
They, I was a drinkie in a, in the, in,
outside of the liquor store.
Just waiting for a taco baka,
there's those half a pine and,
- [Mark] This sounds to me like
you traded alcohol for meth.
- Yes I did.
And that time I did. Yeah.
- [Mark] So I'm not sure one
is better than the other.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] They're both going
to be bad for your baby.
- They're both bad for me.
- [Mark] Bad for you.
- Yeah. And, and, and,
I mean, there's more
things that I wanna talk
but I don't know if I
should say it (chuckles)
cause it's like too much.
It's too,
oh my God.
I just wanna say something.
I just wanna say that
whoever messing around
with that fentanyl shit,
fentanyl or whatever,
how you call that crap.
You're fucking preparing your own grave.
And it is not fun.
My son told me, mom,
that's not a party drug.
Like, Oh, we're gonna party.
No, it's not. It's a drug
that come to kill us.
China made that drug to kill us
and that's what they're doing.
And I was like, wow, like,
and it gets into my head
but it doesn't get into my head.
It's just, it's just crazy.
But it's scary like, it's
very scary, very scary.
I have bad dreams with, with that stuff.
It was very--
- [Mark] You've tried fentanyl
too?
- Yeah, I did try it and
it was horrible when I
wanted to get out of it.
I went seven days cold turkey
and it was the most
horrible feeling in my life.
That was the more anxiety
I never had in my life,
I had it, that those seven days.
And it was horrible.
- [Mark] Wait, what is,
what is stopping you from
quitting altogether everything?
- That either I'm gonna, I'm
gonna end killing my baby
and I'm gonna be alive and going to jail
for the rest of my life.
- [Mark] No, what, what,
what's stopping you?
What's blocking you from stopping drugs?
- The environment that I'm with.
Like,
- [Mark] That you're in Skid Row
where everyone's doing drugs.
- Yeah. Then, yeah, the environment,
the people around me that still do it
and I, and if they do it,
if, I wanna do it too because
I am very like um,
- [Mark] Impulsive?
- I'm very weak, my, like,
I'm very easy to be like,
Oh, shit I wanna hit.
I can't say no.
- [Mark] Then you gotta get outta here.
- Yeah. The thing, that would
be the best thing for me
but I don't wanna leave
Sharkey. (chuckles)
It's kinda hard for me.
It's hard. You know what?
Before I used to cry a lot,
I used to be crying for everything
that happened in my life.
But now I don't.
Now I don't, you know what?
Now,
you know what it's,
it's, it's, it's hard to,
to forget, like my mom,
my mom was, she used,
I used to be a little,
my mom never understood,
never been a mom, like
she never understand um,
to, like, understand, to talk to me
like mom, I ended up all my period.
Oh, I don't wanna, we don't
talk about that shit right here.
Um, I got molested when I was
young, when I was eight and,
and I went and told my mom
that somebody did this to me
and she didn't believe me.
She said,
"You liked that, you wanted
that to happen to you."
And she grabbed the belt
and I will never forget that
she hit me so hard like,
Oh my God. So hard until she was sweating.
And I was like, that's fucked up.
Like, you should have done
that hit to that guy like,
you hit me?
Like you, that's crazy.
And then she used to be very,
I mean,
I, I already forgave her
about that shit, man.
I already did but,
she used to be very disrespectful
to me and my, my brother.
Like, she used to have like,
like, you know, sex with my
dad and didn't stay quiet or,
or knowing that we're like next door
like we don't have a window
and then you, I mean, you can see
so I will be the one that used
to wake up and I'd be like,
fuck man! These mutha fuckers don't stop.
So I used to be angry at them
and the next following
day, I used to tell them,
well you ain't gonna
take a shower or what?
And then I used to tell
my dad the same thing and,
I think all that shit,
That's why I,
I, I feel so um,
how can I tell you like, um,
like I used to be in this,
when I was 10, I used
to be very chunky, okay.
And then my mom used to like
call me like names like,
like fro that's freewheeling
coming walking over here and,
like, Oh, if I was, if
I were to look like you
I would get a gun and
shoot on my head and like,
stuff like that,
It got into my head.
So now I feel like my self
esteem is like in the floor.
You understand?
- [Mark] Yeah.
It's a common story I think.
- Yeah. So--
- [Mark] A lot of people
go through that kind of
childhood stuff and it
impacts their life forever.
- Yeah. So now it's in my head.
So when I try meth and I got very skinny,
that was like, whoa! Now I
know how to lose weight fast.
Now I'm gonna look like I wanna look.
But I was looking horrible.
I was looking horrible, like an old lady.
And you should've seen me when I
finished doing the stupid
fentanyl, I went to the,
to the place where I stay
at, like this homeless place.
I went in the bathroom and
I'm being freaking serious.
You look like a straight out demon.
I went and I looked at
myself and I was like,
what the fuck, are you serious Karina?
My bone, like sticking
out, my face was like,
I said, "Fuck! I look
like a straight up demon.
Like a fucking demon.
That shit is really preparing
you to go to fucking hell.
You, making you so skinny and
repairing your grave to go,
so you can take the last
little hit that you got
and you're done.
And when I went there, I was like, (gasps)
no wonder me and Sharkey we
were fighting so much, like,
look at me like I'm
fucking look so twaked out,
like so druggie, like so smoked out.
I looked so nasty and this,
this people that used to talk to me before
when I used to complain
about my fat, I'm fat,
they'd tell me, Look, Oh,
you lost a lot of weight.
And I say, "I do. I look all
right, I look like a demon."
And then he, and she goes,
but you wanna be skinny.
God don't want you skinny girl,
God got, God wants you how you are.
And if you wanna be somebody else,
this is how you're gonna look
and this is how you're gonna look
by doing it that kind of way.
Like doing drugs, you can
do it, doing exercise.
You always wanna do it the easy way
and it's not the easy way
cause the easy way is the bad way.
So I--
- [Mark] Many people
play around with these drugs
for weight loss reasons.
Do you think?
- Yeah, I'll,
to be honest like, if you,
if you ask all these
girls why you use meth,
always, they don't wanna
like they're in denial like
they don't wanna accept it
but I, I do like, I,
I wanna lose weight,
when I seen that shit,
I say, "Oh no, this is my shit.
I'm gonna stay in this shit."
- [Mark] Is that how it started for you?
Just tryna lose weight?
Is that how it started?
- Yeah. Because look when I
stop and I start gaining weight,
I'm frustrated, like, Oh,
fuck I look disgusting.
Fuck I need some fucking meth.
And then I would do it again
and I would lose it again
and then that's how I'm,
and I cannot, if I stop,
I look like a fucking pig.
It's crazy, it's um, like,
see, everything comes from the past.
You see everything how
it clicks from the past.
My mom calling me names
and it's ended, ended, right like this.
Just like this.
Me doing drugs because
I felt like I was fat, ugly, whatever
because in my house there was
no love, there was nothing.
They were just fighting for
their money and their business.
And, they're still fucking are I think.
They are because my
kids are all fucked up.
My kids are all bad.
My son is in a fucking
program cause he does um,
injects himself with,
I don't know how you call that shit but,
it's some shitty, you put black and you,
some shit on your arm.
He's only 17 and he's fucking
addicted to that shit.
He's in a program right now.
But he looks so different
now but he's clean.
He's been clean for six months.
My other son is either selling dope,
smoking fentanyl, stuck on fentanyl
and selling fentanyl and acid pills
and all kinds of shit at my mom's house.
They already hit my mom
so many fucking times,
but, and they'll when I go
over there they'll be like,
what are you doing here bitch?
Like they say bad words to me like,
and, and I probably, I, I don't know,
probably, I don't know,
maybe I deserve them.
I don't know, but, but
they, they're very bad.
My kids are very, two
of my kids are cutters.
I don't know if you
know about cutters but,
they fuck with the devil and they're,
two of my kids are doing their bush.
I go to mom's house
and only thing you hear
is a fucking devil's music.
In my mom's rooms.
It's crazy.
I seen them cut themselves with knives.
I was like, and I was high on meth.
I was fucking high on meth.
And I used to be tweaking on it
cause it was like, these mutha
fuckers are gonna killing me
in the, in the mutha fucking room.
I used to lock my room cause I felt like
they were gonna kill me.
Mutha fuckers hearing devil music,
they're weejiboo, there
fucking cutting them,
mutha fuckers are gonna end killing my ass
for leaving them alone
and my mom getting them.
That's what's gonna happen.
And, and I used to get like paranoid,
you know they are my kids and
I'm like, what are you doing?
What are you doing in the bathroom?
Well, there's blood everywhere.
What the fuck are you guys doing?
And, nothing, nothing.
And then I will go and find
the knives full of blood.
What the fuck, what you guys do?
Did you guys cut themselves?
Are you guys are stupid as fuck.
Who the fuck does that?
You guys are not normal.
That is not normal.
Who the fuck cuts himself
with the knife for,
for pain, so relieve the pain,
mutha fucker you have more pain like that.
Relieve the pain?
For, I don't believe that shit.
What the fuck, are you made of what?
Do you understand?
So I, I have a lot of problems but,
the good, good thing and the
good part about me right now
is that
I met this man and
he's a good man but he,
he kinda lost like 50 points already.
He had a hundred,
but he lost 50.
And he needs to get them back.
And he, he and, Oh no, he's a good man
but he has ratchet, ratchet moves.
You know like, he still
got ratchet moves like,
like a little whore moves.
You know? I have, I
have a lot of problems.
I have a lot of problems with that but
he's the best man I ever could
have because he's been there.
And he showed me not to be a scary bitch.
You know, I'm almost killing bitches.
I ain't playing.
Cause he showed me this and
I'm doing what he showed me.
- [Mark] So you're living in a Skid Row
if you have a baby in five months?
- No. We're gonna get an apartment.
I don't give a fuck how we're gonna do it.
We got five months to do this
and we gotta do it no matter what.
How we get the pookie and the thing,
that's how we're gonna get the apartment.
That's how it goes.
And then, we have to,
It's just, either, or you
wanna your have your baby too,
cause for real, as soon as they come out
and the baby doesn't have nowhere to go,
they're gonna get him.
And they're gonna get,
and they can get him easy.
They could just, somebody
can get him so easy
cause he's so little.
It's like, oh, he's very little and then,
It's very easy for
somebody to get that baby.
You know and, and I already
have a, a, a open case
with my other son, is,
is, is very, very hard.
So if I don't show him that I'm okay
that I have a fucking
job and I have apartment
and I have everything there
and I finished my program in
those months that they told me,
cause I'm very blessed for
this Corona virus going on
it fucked people up
but it fucking, it helped
me in some way because
they were about to take my
rights as a mother on, on March.
And because of this shit
happened, they fucking said,
they give me eight more
months to finish my program
and get my baby back.
So now it's, it's on me now.
- You understand?
- [Mark] I do.
- So, so it's on me though.
I better be, so I better get my ass and,
that's the way I get, get my,
you know, my little things
and, I can't get my baby back.
I like to party, then I
have to be responsible.
And I'm not and I have to learn.
- [Mark] All right, Karina.
Well, thank you for sharing your story
and good luck with your baby.
- [Karina] Yeah.
Maybe when I have the baby
I'll come back and I'll do a,
a family interview.
- [Mark] I hope you get it all.
If you get clean and get
your your act together
between now and then.
- [Karina] I will. Maybe, yeah.
That's gonna be a promise.
I'm gonna come back with my babies
and I'm gonna an interview.
- [Mark] Excellent.
- [Karina] That will be
a good interview.
- [Mark] Thank you.
- [Karina] well, okay.
Now we are done, no, let me--
- [Mark] You were worried
to say you were right.
(mumbles)